est ce que vous pensez des transports au
combat à paris c'est un petit peu le
bordel quand même niveau horaire il ya
que deux trains par heure et votre frère
qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent pareil c'est
la galère c'est vrai que franchement
c'est non christophe serre au look parce
qu'en fait on l'attendait frei perlot
échelle jamais quoi qu'est ce que vous
pensez des transports en commun
parisiens madame je n'aime pas c'est
vrai non je ne les aime pas et votre
sort pour ce quoi un pareil vraiment je
les aime pas du tout à tingo m'évite
mistura mauresmo qui ne le sait mais on
ne se le dise c'est très compliqué c'est
très chaud c'est très chargé et ça sent
pas très bon d'accord votre sol en pense
quoi
pareil franchement c'est compliqué c'est
vrai qu'on a du mal à trouver le bout de
bois et c'est quand même plus ça c'est
relou pat thiébaut pas hyper luis parce
que vous pensez transport en combat à
paris les gars part il ya trop de monde
ya trop de monde
non ça veut subir vos frères et
présentant ce poids de franchement t'as
vu bien tranquille placide pour la
grande motte
les moyens de transports parisiens pour
moi qui suis un provincial sont bien et
votre frère vous pensez qu'ils en
pensent quoi le cas partie et c'est vrai
que j'ai toujours
finalement c'est toujours lui d'alger à
partir